>> So, let's look at the last quantity that
we haven't talked about so far. And that is the
probability of the hypothesis. Well, just like the probability of
D is the prior on the data, this is in
fact your prior on the hypothesis. So, just like
the probability of D is a prior on the data.
The probability of H is a prior on a particular
hypothesis drawn from the hypothesis space. So in other words,
in encapsulates our prior belief that one hypothesis is likely
or unlikely compared to other hypotheses. So in fact what's
really neat about this from a sort of AI point
of view is that the prior ,as its called, is in
fact our domain knowledge. So if every angle that we've
seen so far, everything that we've said there's always some
place where we stick in out domain knowledge. Are prior
belief about the way the world works. Whether that's a similarity
metric for Knn It, it's something about which
features might be important, so we care about high
information gain and decision trees, or our belief
about the, the structure of a neural network. Those
are prior beliefs, those are, that represents the
main knowledge. And here in Bayesian Learning, here in
this notion of, of Bayes' Rule, all of our
prior knowledge sits here in the probability or prior
probability over the hypotheses. Does that all make sense?
>> Yeah its really interesting I guess. So we talked about things like
kernels and similarity functions as ways
of capturing this kind of domain knowledge.
And I guess, I guess what its saying is that its maybe tending
to prefer or assign higher probability to
hypothesis that group things a certain way.
>> exactly right. So, in fact, when you use something
like Euclidian distance in KNN, what you're saying is,'Well,
points that are closer together ought to have, similar labels, and so,
we would believe any hypothesis that puts points that are physically close to
one another to have similar outputs, we would say, are more likely than
ones that put points that are very close together to have different outputs.
>> Neat.
>> So let me just mention one last thing
before I give you a quiz, okay? So, see
if this makes sense, I'm a see if you
really understand Bayes' rule. So let's imagine that I wanted
to know under what circumstances the, probability of a hypothesis, given the
data, goes up. What on the right side of the equation would
you expect to change, go up or go down, or stay the
same, that would influence whether the probability of a hypothesis goes up.
>> So the probability of the hypothesis given
the data, what could make that combined quantity
go up, so one is looking at the
right hand side, the probability of the hypothesis,
so, so if you have a hypothesis that has
a higher prior, has, is more likely to be
a good one. Before you see the data then
that would raise it after you see the data too.
>> Right.
>> And I guess the probability of the data given the hypothesis should
go up. Oh, which is kind of like accuracy. It's kind of like
saying that if you pick a hypothesis that does a better job of
labeling the data, then also your probability of the hypothesis will go up.
>> Right. Anything else?
>> I guess the probability of the data going
down. But that's not really a change from the hypothesis.
>> Right. But it is true that if those
goes down, then the probability in the hypothesis can and
the data will go up. But as you point
out, it's not connected to the hypothesis directly. And I'll
write in equation for you in, in just a
moment that'll kind of make that, I think, a little
bit clearer. Okay, but you got all this, right? So
I think you understand it. So we got Bayes' Rule.
And, notice what we've done. We've gone from this sort
of general notion of saying we need to find the best
hypothesis, to actually coming up with an equation, that sort
of makes explicit what we mean by that. That what we
care about is the probability of some hypothesis given the
data. That's what we mean by best. And that, that can
be further thought as, the probablity of us seeing, some labels
on some data, given hypothesis. Times the probability of the hypothesis,
even without any data whatsoever, normalized by the
probability of the data. So let's play around with
Bayes' rules a little bit and make certain that
we all, we all kind of get it. Okay?
>> Sure.
>> Okay.